wait three months yeah let's launch it
in June let's launch it in may not let's
launch it in February everybody forgot
you either look you just made you forgot
that his book came out four months ago
came out and I didn't know that it did I
mean it's just three months ago the book
came out it just it happened and then it
kind of disappeared that's terrible bro
I didn't die the point is I don't know
it should have launched right about now
yeah
you launched today on on the on the
Twitter spaces today's the day you
launched well again his biggest problem
is that he has a marketing problem
that's you know so he's gonna have to
address that